shaima benedit 18 ans n'a pas hésité à
pousser les portes du gymnase guimier
pour participer au premier grand forum
job d'été de l'apprentissage de trappes
sous cette formule
l'objectif de cette lycéenne en
terminale es trouver un emploi pour la
période estivale niveau dans mon lycée
on nous a on nous a distribué en fait
des petites feuilles
du coup je suis parti me renseigner à la
cyberbase et voilà on m'a dit on m'a dit
le concept et je trouvais le concept
assez intéressant de ramener différence
entre prix des places
shy'm avez la possibilité de rencontrer
une quarantaine d'entreprises des
professionnels qui ont travaillé pour
non plus de deux mois avec la mairie
pour participer à cet événement en fait
le but pour nous ça va être de trouver
notamment des stagiaires des alternants
cdd cdi qui pourrait correspondre donc à
nos offres les compétences ne m'importe
m'importe peu ce que je cherchais des
personnalités après plus d'une heure de
recherches et une quinzaine de cv
distribué l'étudiant de 18 ans dresse un
premier bilan
c'est un salon qui est assez intéressant
parce que voilà j'ai fait plusieurs
plusieurs stands sont assez différents
on nous parle de l'entreprise de ce
qu'ils font particulièrement de ce
qu'ils proposent
l'événement a attiré plus de 500 jeunes
vu le succès rencontré cette année le
rendez vous devrait être renouvelée
l'année prochaine